tu parles de je donne hey cinquante
dollars donc ça te rend riche c'est un
début hmm est-ce que tu me montes si fort je ne
te monte pas bébé j'essaie de te faire
comprendre et tu sais comment je gère ma
maison maintenant toi  tu vas devoir aller à l'
école ou tu vas devoir aller
travailler maintenant je m'en fous si tu es un
concierge je m'en fous de ce que diable oui je suis
propriétaire de l'entreprise je sais je sais que tu
ne le fais pas  Je ne possède pas la société Lonzo
pensez-vous que nous en avons fini ici ouais je veux dire que vous en
gardez quelques-uns comme quelque chose à me dire
vous vous fichez de ce pour quoi je me bats d'accord
je sais déjà ce que je veux faire de ma
vie  et ce n'est certainement pas assis dans
une cabine à prendre des commandes maintenant
j'ai travaillé d'arrache-pied pour nous amener ici et je
refuse de te laisser tout jeter toi